Hello Freak bitches.
Yeah,
I know somebody to talk to a
cop and they said that when,
how they started working
and then 11 years later,
oh yeah.
Going into those areas where these things
always happened and after years and
years,
it just,
it just wears on you for sure.
And I know from the air,
it's just me drawing up in situations,
you know what I mean?
I wouldn't want to go back.
I barely go back there,
you know,
so,
but it do give you nerves.
Your nerves heighten.
It naturally kicks in 100%,
you know,
and like,
yeah.
And some people can't handle those nerves.
You learn how to breathe quietly.
You don't know.
Like somebody,
you could walk down the street and
somebody could pull a pistol out on those
things though.
I've been driving down the street when
my ex lady and she was talking and I was
like,
get down because I saw God draw on a
corner and shoot across the street at
another guy.
Oh,
Jane has the gun went up.
We drove under the,
the the the fire,
right?
Oh,
it was long.
It was long.
Oh my God.
And as it went up,
we went under,
oh no,
we got a second shot off
and I drove and I was like,
man,
that was crazy.
Like I'm that guy like late,
like,
you know,
we made that was crazy.
And she was like you and call the police
in her life of what is he like to tell
what happened?
And that was like,
I don't want to be,
and that's how crazy is that way you
don't even want to be involved because you
gotta go to the cops and I
ain't up calling the police.
And um,
he's like,
he described the victim.
I was like white tee shirt,
blue jeans,
that's all I say it.
And that it was like,
was he black?
And it was just a law.
Paul's,
there's a long pause and they like,
sir,
is he black?
And I was like,
no,
you know that nick was black.
You know,
if you can help somebody out and they
can get rid of it or change the way you
think.
I,
he,
Joe Schilling Mani did Simon [inaudible]
relationship with his dad was miles
better before he passed away.
It wasn't that pretty powerful.
Yeah.
Joe talked about it on the podcast.
He talked about it just,
it's completely changed
his whole perception of his
relationship with his dad,
who his dad was in his life
and just he let it all go.
Yeah.
And that just helped him tremendously.
What more can you say
the na really as a coach,
I mean,
Ian Mccall had said,
you know,
I know they didn't get his fight with
Justin Scoggins and that because of the
weight,
whatever her name was saying that his
life has changed since two inside mine
therapy and doing the,
you know,
work with me,
not just timeline therapy and not just
hypnosis with my coach and in general,
cause it's multifaceted really.
And um,
he said he's lives changed.
He,
he's a different person.
People have no [inaudible].
We know.
So that's,
for me it's great news.
I think sometimes it just
takes the realization of
what's been fucking with you.
That once you realize what it is,
then you have it in your mind and then
you can kind of look at it for what it
really is.
Instead of this like thing that's playing
in the background that you can't quite
identify or you or you know what
exists but you ignore and you just,
you
don't,
you don't ever get over it.
Yeah.
He says he's interested in I to a
client the other week called joy.
She's 80 years of age and she was going
to a wedding in Spain for our grandson
and she was beside herself.
She was terrified,
you know,
and we did it.
Just a few things,
you know,
little things to make you
consider different ways of
looking at the anxiety she
was getting because
anxiety is basically a,
you should have your unconscious mind
is to focus on what you want because if
you're in an anxious state,
you're focusing on what you don't want,
right.
There's different levels of it.
Of course.
Wait,
she was focusing on what may go wrong,
instead of saying all this will go
into a wedding is a celebration of two
People's matrimony,
whatever,
and it's going to be nice and Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
She wasn't focused on that.
She was focused on something else.
I changed that and like she was happy
and she went to the wedding and it's,
you know,
he's got,
I mean,
she's 80 years of age.
He might not be going
to Lowe's or weddings,
let's be honest.
Right.
But if for me,
the job itself,
what can you say about nice?
He's,
it transforms people,
you know,
and I adore it.
Mark Spitz.
That's right.
I don't remember that guy.
He was a 76 Olympics I think.
Is that right?
It has to be it.
He looks like Burt
Reynolds from deliverance.
What?
72 72.
Yeah,
man.
That's right.
I forgot about that guy.
Okay.
So he was the first of the,
um,
the superstar Michael Phelps type
swimmer dudes I think before,
um,
I want to say before Phelps came
along and I really don't know,
but I think that spits was the guy who
won the most gold medals up until that
moment and then Phelps just
fucking blew him out of the water.
Where is he now?
Um,
if I had to guess,
by the way,
it looks in an Burt
Reynolds movie in the 1970s.
Yeah,
I'm looking at him.
I hope that guy still rocks that look,
I wonder if being in water
more than a more average,
the average person is
better or worse for your,
your skin.
For every probably worse because
chlorine is not good for you.
It's not good for Ya.
Chlorine kills everything
that's in the water,
but it also fucks with the
floor of your own skin.
Like it's,
it's not the best stuff in
the world for your skin.
I mean,
it's sterile water.
What about saltwater?
That's probably better for you.
Yeah.
Let's say salt water's better for ya.
So water is interesting man,
because I can't get it in my eyes.
I know some people can
get it in their eyes.
They don't have a problem with it.
I get it in my eyes,
it fucking stings.
I don't know why.
Like when I go to,
uh,
the,
the beach,
if I get water in my eyes,
it fucking stinks.
Oh,
is that add to your sodium levels?
He's not.
It's mark.
Spitz wasn't even using a swim cap.
When you're saying in
your eyes were stinging.
He doesn't have goggles
on either price on it.
Yeah,
but I'm talking about a pool.
He swam in a pool and the
ocean is where my eyes sting.
Huh?
But uh,
yeah,
Mark Spitz was,
the old school is,
fuck,
he probably swam in a flannel shirt.
Those are looking at his body.
They're going to shore.
He sorts of probably made
from like red dye number nine.
They didn't do any strength
and conditioning back
there stops showing me just
men in their underwear.
Jamie,
stop it.
The iconic speedo indoors.
So this,
uh,
go to full body on this gentlemen.
Look at his fucking body.
Man.
I'd like,
you mean,
I guess he kind of looks like an athlete
or he looks like a your girlfriend's
brother that's staying with her over the,
you know,
you get up in the morning,
you meet him for the first time.
Well,
how you doing man?
Nice to meet you.
Oh Hey man.
Hey,
y'all got soap?
Like that's what he looks like.
He's like some,
some weird fucking dude might've worked
out a couple of times in his underwear.
Like,
why are you just in your,
in your underwear?
Like that dude with gold
chains around your neck.
This is a fucking strange picture.
It doesn't really look to
swim swimmer body either.
Like the difference between that body
and Michael Phelps body or any swimmer
nowadays,
it's like pretty different.
Like his legs,
he actually seemed Kinda Chubby.
They're like,
uh,
I don't know.
They don't really seem
muscularity kind of seems sexy.
Well,
um,
what,
you got,
you beat a guy like Robbie Lawler.
You knock 'em out and in one round you've
got to think the momentum coming off
of that.
It's gotta be stunning.
I would love to see fantasy UFC like a
show where they take maybe the fighters
that have retired or people that aren't
as good as the other fires and have him
like almost do like game
show stuff like this.
Like you have to do a game go.
All right,
so this fight,
you have your shoes tied,
you have to hold a
banana and not crush it.
You have to protect this banana,
like it's a baby,
you know,
like fun things like that.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like where you saying,
cause I think even as I think as
a fight it would still be fun.
Just the hat,
throwing the other options.
Like almost like a video game,
you know,
where go the doctor,
I've told you many times
something wrong screen.